hey I've talked before about homeopathy
and homeopathy is based on the idea that
you can dilute active ingredients more
and more and that the more you dilute
them the more powerful they get in terms
of treating conditions or symptoms or
diseases I was recently at a party with
someone or were we were talking about of
the Green Party used to support
homeopathy in a friend of mine said yeah
which doesn't work and this person at
the party I was at said well actually it
does and I chose not to fight that fight
but as we know we've seen countless
reports now would say homeopathy is
nothing it does nothing it's not a valid
treatment for anything uh many
homeopathic products are actually so
deluded that when you test them there is
no detectable quantity of the substance
that it claims to be now the Federal
Trade Commission is actually saying that
when you make homeopathic treatments it
has to say on the label that it has not
been demonstrated by any scientific
testing to actually do what it claims to
do this is very good news because
Americans are spending years ago nearly
ten years ago it was three billion
dollars a year on homeopathy that's a
number that has probably gone up more
and now the quote no scientific evidence
of of a functionality of efficacy is
going to be a required message on a lot
of these products I think this is very
good Pat and I know a lot of people say
well listen David the placebo effect is
very popular and homeopathy can work via
the placebo effect you have to remember
something you have to test products
versus a placebo so if all the argument
is that homeopathy is better than
nothing that's not a really strong case
for billions of dollars in spending you
have to prove that homeopathy as a
placebo is better than another placebo I
don't even really know what that means
and that seems totally lost on some of
the people that only talk about placebo
I don't think a lot of people are gonna
trust the authority from the FTC on this
I mean if there was something like this
game will not entertain you as a label
do you think people would buy it I don't
think so uh I don't know I actually
think that Eve that the believers in
this are not going to be dissuaded they
will just try
get up to say that's Big Pharma big
pharma doesn't want you buying this so
so they've lobbied to have something put
on homeopathy but it many people like to
say you need to study it more it hasn't
been studied enough yet to know whether
it really works or not well number one
it doesn't pass the common sense sniff
test right uh you deluded more and more
and it becomes more and more powerful
which makes absolutely no sense and then
we do have many scientific studies on
this and I will also mention a major
issue is that in many stores the
homeopathic products are displayed right
next to the what i would call
evidence-based products or products with
actual active ingredients that's not a
good thing because that also is
inherently deceptive or gives the wrong
idea to many consumers so this is
actually a decision from the FTC that I
do agree with